US President Barack Obama is sending 30,000 more US troops to Afghanistan.
They should all be there by about the middle of 2010,...
...but he also plans to start withdrawing American forces a year later.
In a previous edition of "Now You Know", we took a look at the threat posed by the Taliban...
...in Afghanistan.
It's a resurgent Taliban in large parts of Afghanistan.
I've seen estimates that they control as much as 60%,...
...if not more of the country.
Taliban, the word means, "students", students of Islam. Their Islamic religious schools are called, "madrasahs".
Many young men and boys fled Afghanistan during the war with the Soviets in the 1980s,...
...ending up in madrasahs in mostly northwest Pakistan.
These youngsters are being taught that Islam is under threat,...
...which is the philosophy of those schools and that Islam needs to be defended,...
...and that these youngsters have a role to play.
These madrasahs are the principal production centers, if you wanna call it that...
...of the suicide bombers.
The end of the war with the Soviets did not bring peace and stability to Afghanistan, just more wars,...
...civil war, and an almost total lack of law and order.
In that vacuum, you had these warlords stepping in...
...and these warlords were committing terrible atrocities: murder, rape, killing and looting.
It was the Taliban that promised to bring law and order to Afghanistan in the mid-1990s.
Mullah Mohammed Omar emerged as leader of the Taliban...
...after he ordered an Afghan warlord hanged for rape.
That act of him, executing the commander for that kidnapping and rape...
...is what immediately started to form a following around him.
There was chaos and the Taliban promised to bring an end to it.
And they did.